Let's take a quick look at how to deploy Node.js
applications to Google App Engine. I have
a Node.js app that runs great on my local
machine. It's important to use the PORT environment
variable as well as "npm start" to run our
code. To deploy our code, go to "cloud.google.com".
Sign into your Google Account if you haven't
done so already, and then go to "My Console".
Make sure you sign up for the free trial if
you haven't done that yet. Now go to "select
a project" and "create a project". Give you
project a name, and click create. Then, go
to the Compute Engine section, and make sure
Billing is enabled. If you don't have the
Google Cloud SDK installed on your computer,
see the link in the description for how to
install it. In the same directory as your
"package.json", create a file called "app.yaml"
with the following information. Run "gcloud
init" to login to your Google Account. Now
run "gcloud preview app deploy" to deploy
your application. In a few minutes, your application
should be deployed. Go to the URL and you
can see your application running on the cloud!